Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
One of the holy grail problems of machine
learning research is to achieve artificial
general intelligence, AGI in short.
Deep Blue was able to defeat the genius Kasparov
in Chess, but it was unable to tell us what
the time was.
Algorithms of this type we often refer to
as a weak AI, or narrow AI, a technique that
excels, or is maybe even on a superhuman level
at a task, but has zero or no knowledge about
anything else.
A key to extend these algorithms would be
to design them in a way that their knowledge
generalizes well to other problems.
This is what we call transfer learning, and
this collaboration between the Stanford AI
lab and Caltech goes by the name Neural Task
Programming, and tries to tackle this problem.
A solution to practically any problem we're
trying to solve can be written as series of
tasks.
These are typically complex actions, like
cleaning a table, or performing a backflip
that are difficult to transfer to a different
problem.
This technique is a bit like divide and conquer
type algorithms that aggressively try to decompose
big, difficult tasks into smaller, more manageable
pieces.
The smaller and easier to understand the pieces
are, the more reusable they are and the better
they generalize.
Let's have a look at an example.
For instance, in a problem where we need to
pick and place objects, this series of tasks
can be decomposed into picking and placing.
These can be further diced into a series of
even smaller tasks, such as gripping, moving,
and releasing actions.
However, if the learning takes place like
this, we can now specify different variations
of these tasks, and the algorithm will quickly
understand how to adapt the structure of these
small tasks to efficiently to solve new problems.
The new algorithm generalizes really well
for tasks with different lengths, topologies,
and changing objectives.
If you take a look at the paper, you'll also
find some more information on adversarial
dynamics, which lists some problem variants
where a really unpleasant adversary pushes
things around on the table from time to time
to mess with the program, and there are some
results that show that the algorithm is able
to recover from these failure states quite
well.
Really cool.
Now, please don't take this as a complete
solution for AGI, because it is a fantastic
piece of work, but it's definitely not that.
However, it may be a valuable puzzle piece
to build towards the final solution.
This is research.
We advance one step at a time.
Man, what an amazing time to be alive.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!